in what is now a completely undeniable
scandal of this very early Trump
administration we have learned that
indeed the Trump aids Trump campaign
aides and staffers that were suspected
to have been in contact with Russian
officials were indeed in contact with
Russian officials during the 2016
presidential campaign you'll probably
recall that one of the constant and
repeated denials from the Trump team has
been we were never in touch with Russia
during the presidential election we know
though about countless overlaps between
Trump and Russia because they've been
revealed Russian hacking for example
directed by the highest authority in
Russia was meant to help Donald Trump
defeat Hillary Clinton
we know that shamed national security
advisor Michael Flynn will now former
national security adviser Michael Flynn
did indeed discuss Russian sanctions
before the inauguration with the Russian
ambassador to the US something that he
lied about and denied and again
ultimately resigning in shame just about
48 hours ago Donald Trump's former
campaign manager Paul Manafort resigned
after his dealings with Russia including
possible illegal payments from Russia
were uncovered and then we have the
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
couldn't possibly be more Russia
connected actually was given an award by
Vladimir Putin about what would a great
friend to Russia he was in his dealings
as former Exxon CEO and of course we
have the blackmail file relating to what
Russia has on Donald Trump it's been
partially proven to contain accurate
information and we may soon learn more
about the accuracy of the content
but-but-but-but Trump's team wasn't in
touch with Russia during the campaign
right right wrong phone records and
intercepted phone calls now confirm that
members of Donald Trump's presidential
campaign team as well as other Trump
associates were in contact with senior
Russian intelligence officials in the
year leading up to the election so many
sub stories to this we've learned that
the information that I just relayed to
you was actually obtained around the
same time that
American intelligence and law
enforcement discovered Russian hacking
was meant to help Trump by hacking into
the DNC we now know that James Comey
could have also done a press conference
about this information but he chose not
to and only did a press conference about
the investigation into Hillary Clinton's
emails you know because none of it was
political right Pat except we had a
press conference and a letter from James
Comey at the FBI about Hillary Clinton
but not about what was being
investigated regarding Donald Trump that
in and of itself is a scandal - we'll
just have to wait and see what the
intelligence community comes up with I
guess I mean when the initial BuzzFeed
story broke I think there were plenty of
red flags and reasons to be skeptical
yeah but now that nine US intelligence
officials are confirming parts of the
story now that we have these intercepted
phone calls and records I mean there's a
lot more legitimacy here and let's
continue exploring that legitimacy now
that we know that Donald Trump's team
and Russian intelligence were in contact
the question is do we have proof that
they were actively colluding we don't we
don't currently have proof of that but
again with every passing week almost
with every passing day I think is more
accurate the known connections between
Donald Trump and Russia are growing so I
wouldn't be surprised if that's
ultimately proven here's what's amazing
the intercepted phone data shows that
when Donald Trump publicly would show up
and all of a sudden we would say why is
he saying so many positive things about
Russian President Vladimir Putin the
phone records show Pat that Trump
associates were in touch with Russian
intelligence during that time the timing
of this could not be more damning indeed
one of the people on these intercepted
calls was Paul Manafort this is the
biggest scandal ridden administration of
the last 20 years
and were 25 days in and just look back
at the interviews of what Trump has said
about Putin and Russia he would never
criticize them yeah even when Bill
O'Reilly one of his teammates in the
Republican field would something like
well Putin is a bad guy he kills a lot
of people he would write that off and
say well we do the same thing it's
absolutely stunning defense from from
anybody but but particularly from a
Republican and as usual Donald Trump is
writing
it all off he tweeted about it this
morning saying this Russian connection
nonsense is merely an attempt to cover
up the many mistakes made in Hillary
Clinton's losing campaign who's talking
about the mistakes made by Hillary
Clinton at this point such that you
would need something so elaborate to
cover it up it doesn't make any sense
also Donald Trump tweeting later on that
the what matters here is that this
information was leaked remember when we
had the Hillary Clinton email stuff
going on and at the time Trump was
saying hey how it was leaked doesn't
matter we should only focus on the
contents and now all of a sudden Donald
Trump doesn't want to focus on the
content he wants to focus only on how we
found out about this the one other
thought about this from the Russian
perspective there is a geopolitical book
by Alexander Dugan called
the foundations of geopolitics the
geopolitical future of Russia
it's from 1997 and there's a quote that
I'm going to read to you which is very
relevant to what's going on right now
quote in the United States Russia should
use its special forces within the
borders of the United States to fuel
instability and separatism
for instance provoke african-american
racists Russia should introduce
geopolitical disorder into internal
American activity encouraging all kinds
of separatism and ethnic social and
racial conflicts actively supporting all
dissident movements extremist racist and
sectarian groups thus destabilizing
internal political processes in the u.s.
it would also make sense simultaneously
to support isolationist tendencies in
American politics 20 years ago this was
written it is happening it is happening
and there are two major stories here in
my mind pad number one is the facts
right the facts of what we are learning
regarding communication between the
Trump campaign and Russian intelligence
but there's another story which is the
fact that the Donald Trump team has been
blanket denying all of this for as long
as we remember his lies
they have been lying to us and let's
remember that free and fair elections
are a hallmark of our democracy if there
was an interference there I mean that's
Watergate 2.0 yeah it Rison that's being
made which is there are a lot of aspects
like Watergate and I mean it's so it's
just so naive apparently Pat to think
that the rule of law and separation of
powers and actual outside non-political
investigations into these things might
take place but at the end of the day
Infowars Breitbart and Fox News aren't
reporting on this so I guess it must all
be fake news when does anyone recall by
the way this level of hostility and
opposition between the sitting president
and intelligence agencies that's another
aspect of this that is absolutely you
know if I were Trump and I was learning
all of the stuff that Intel has on me I
don't know that I'd be continually
picking fights with them yeah I mean to
answer your question maybe j edgar
hoover during his reign but i mean you
have to go back pretty far you got to go
back pretty far to get to that